on a vraiment besoin de ces dix sept
mille cinq cents demandes de logements
qui sont pas satisfaites et 7000
logements vacants c'est pourquoi c'est
pas vrai nous n'avons mais c'est le
turnover non sur 94 milles mais faudra
vous renseigner sur 94 me c'est le
turnover normal et donc on a un peu le
logement amour sur des gens peu
logements vacants sur des gens et on à
7500 demande de logements non satisfaite
et il a fallu construire pour d'abord
remplir les objectifs que la loi nous
fixait puisque nous n'avions pas 20 % de
logements locatifs à loyer modéré nous
les avons maintenant à l'époque madame
duflot voulez qu'on aille jusqu'à 25
pour rappel quand ma fille l'élan
qu'elle proposait pas d'arrêter ou de
stopper la construction elle proposait
d'aller plus avant et elle avait raison
parce que quand on construit on permet
d'avoir dévoyé des loyers qui sont pas
trop élevés et c'est pour cela que à
dijon on a plus d'habitants parce que
les habitants ne fuit plus la ville
centre c'est la seule ville centre de
tout le grand est qui gagnent des
habitants